For modular multiplication,
the story is a bit more complicated.
First, similar to modular
addition,in modular multiplication
the result of x times y not m is
the remainder of x times y divided by m.
In modular multiplication,
the result of a number times
its inverse, MOD M, is one.
For example, if the modular is 10,
then three and seven are inverse
of each other because three times
seven is 21 and 21 MOD 10 is one.
Because, the remainder of
21 divided by 10 is one.
It turns out, that, for a given modular,
only some numbers have inverse.
For example, if the modular is 10,
then the numbers two,
five, six, eight do not have inverse.
For example, for the number two,
can you find its inverse,
say x, such that two times x,
MOD 10 is one?
There's no such x.
The great mathematician Euclid invented
the method to find multiplicative
inverse.
That is, for the modular n given X,
Euclid had an algorithm to find Y.
Such that X times Y mod N equal to one.
Euclid also proved that only
the numbers relatively prime to N
has MOD N multiplicative inverse.